so dee you've just been in baltimore and
maine this whole time maine
baltimore phoenix yeah nashville now
back in baltimore you're floating around
i'm floating man
also there's nothing those are also the
only places that are open but like
nashville in phoenix yeah you can get up
and like that's true and [ __ ] around you
know
baltimore was open they closed that [ __ ]
down but and how's it going with your
girl and her family
it was going good but how long have you
been though have you ever said you're
welcome
i think so yeah this is the problem yeah
we didn't we're gonna go
several months well they were like come
stay covered baby
yeah come come stay and we were like oh
we don't have to we kind of like the
woods you know
we're doing our own thing and they're
like oh no come come stay
so you go stay in their house and man i
i think they were like as slowly as time
went by they were like oh he's a he's a
[ __ ]
like i'm pretty sure i think he's he's
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah he's black sam said
i left i fly out yesterday to come here
the moment i had a party the moment i
left they had a party and they were like
hey so
he smokes wheat huh oh yeah is he
smoking the weed are you smoking a lot
of weed at the house
never in the house but yeah smoke weed
outside the house yeah but
are you high 24 7 around the family no
20 12 six 3.5
so but you're just like chill are you
like eating all their [ __ ]
no we don't touch i'm trying to get the
vibe here don't touch it because i'm
very nervous about it because i'm like
you know it's tough to get comfortable
at
your your girlfriend's house right yeah
i mean luckily you ain't blowing up the
bathroom
we got our own spot like the basement so
the baby in the basement
it's it's own apartment i'm tired of
putting my clothes in the basement you
know what i mean okay
i agree but yeah okay okay it is a nice
place though it is
more free property open yeah yeah so
you're staying there with your girl
in the basement everything's good you
guys eating dinners together
we always go eat dinner with the fan
because they invite they're like hey
come up and eat dinner and they come
what do they make it what they make they
can cook
or is it white it's like real white
people though hold on speak your truth
man do it white people taco night is
real dawg
it's fantastic it's like taco tuesday
taco tuesday but it's just you know when
it's real lebron tried claiming taco
tuesday
i'm trademarking taco tuesday was like
it's already what happy hour friday
he just got to l.a he didn't know he
didn't know what he was what the rules
were
dumb but yeah like white [ __ ] bro
everything is everything
is a pot roast yeah [ __ ] yeah you like
that
oh yeah yeah keep going what else oh god
she's all excited everything's just
burgers
you know what i mean she's burgers did
she introduce you to the scallops yet
bro hey scallops go harder potato
scallops come on bro
yeah uh i got in the crab since i've
been out there oh crabs crazy oh you
[ __ ] with crab crab cakes crab soup oh
yeah that's big out there yeah
yeah that's just fire okay so let me get
this straight go ahead because
he's not eating nice nice nice place to
live
they're making crab meals mac and cheese
pot roast
where's the problem here okay problem
the real problem is i'm just there
they don't want you around they don't
want me again have you overstayed your
welcome you know what i'm saying like
you're probably like all right dude
dude i feel it but this is my thing i
was like we would have never came
sam wanted to go because she wants to
spend time with her family i'm like you
know absolutely
kovid we're not doing we're just sitting
here in l.a let's go sometimes we spend
some time with my family hurt okay let's
do that let's spin i haven't seen my
family in forever
let's go see your face that's a long
time it's a long time bro
they're not [ __ ] having it man so how
do you know did they give you a timeline
or anything they never said anytime they
just said come
they just said come so what do you
expect him to do
but what are they doing like how do you
know that you they don't want you there
anymore
they told sam that they don't want us
there anymore
as soon as i left you guys you got you
got it out of here derek is it both
parents or one parent
it's one that's the thing and it's the
stuff that's his dad loves me
the dad loves me loves that and they're
they're white white
white white white white why is it white
that parent
that stepmom she's always at home stay
home mom
exactly oh there it is i like where
you're going but the kids are grown
kids are growing everybody's out the
house everyone's it's it's except you
it's me so you're her
brother she's got down syndrome who
lives there oh but she takes care of the
kid with down she takes care of the kid
you
me and him kicking it [ __ ] cracking
jokes watching back to the future way
too many
times but i don't mind this is this is
how you do it so it's not like this
sounds like peanut butter falcon part
two
yeah but yeah bro and then you could
feel it i could feel it though when i
was leaving of like
of like oh man you're going to go out to
la be great if you could just stay out
there huh you know
you're just like yeah it would and you
think it's cause you're black
definitely because i'm black part of it
why are you saying she's making comments
there's all the comments like during the
riots you're like wished they would have
got in
no during the white people rioted on the
recent one and her
i didn't it's also i never talked
politics i just walked upstairs and she
was like you see this
i mean this is bad but imagine if it was
the other side right derek and i was
like i mean yeah
[ __ ] can't act right was that what you
want from me we don't know how to act
is that what you want like what the [ __ ]
do you want lady also it's like bro
i don't i hated to just are they into
politics in the politics so i'm you soon
i'm just there dude and like me going
like oh no no no i'm
like i mean comedian like this is like
i've been doing before i met her
and y'all this is what i was doing and i
was in this [ __ ]
i was in and are they mad because you're
not like chris rock
matt that bro to them it's like you know
the kind of people you talk to and
they're like
oh well i mean you know there's derrick
and then there's like chris rock well
you're not you can't be chris rock and
it's like
you're like well how did you know there
was a point where chris rock wasn't
chris rock yeah like
they don't see that they don't
understand the journey i don't
understand that there's a journey that
yeah
you know patrick mahomes didn't go from
high school to [ __ ] the best player
in the nfl
there's some stops along there there's
some stuff there's some troubles
there's some bumps yeah but they're not
you know you just talk to people and
they're not they don't see that man they
don't
like my parents get out of there man i
don't that's why we have to do that
those that that energy is that why
you're going back to the ladies
dude that's why we have going to the
main and they're going to call her a
cracker and leave
i kind of want to know what about a cave
baby okay baby's in dirt have you ever
heard of cave babies no what does that
mean
bro it's an ugly girl that lives in a
cave it's a bad like give a girl
ugly like oh that's a cave babe ugly
girl or guy oh guy yeah
uh love island season three and a new
girl came out ooh that's a cave baby
she's like what's a cave baby went it's
an ugly [ __ ] that lives in a cave and
she was like okay
yeah she was like oh okay i guess that's
a thing yes that's just what is it now
[ __ ]
you'll hear about this there's a lot
more around this house
baby
yeah is your girl heart broken about is
she close with a stepmom
heartbroken just because of the
non-belief yo when i told her
i told her i was on she was like so what
were you doing before all this
i was like oh i was on tour and then
literally called it happened like yeah
stop like it just stopped just stopped
everything that was it and she goes
were you on tour or was your nfl friend
just taking care of you
oh and i'm like how did do you even know
darren how the [ __ ] did we get here
you won and like she look you up or
something you never told her
no i did your podcast so she probably i
think she saw the malik episode thank
you
weird bro that was crazy that one and
then like or or like
saying things of like uh you know like
oh were you a comedian or were your
parents are just helping you and like
stuff like that where you're like oh
this is
i can't she has a little bit of racism
in her you can feel it it feels like
she's watching cnn like [ __ ] derek
the goddamn problem and we're helping
them out
this one night about healthcare and i
was like why am i talking about this
she was just like something like how no
one deserves health care like unless you
earn it and i'm like
i mean yeah but who care like who cares
right and poor people get health care i
don't like it doesn't affect
like what you know they should they
should earn it like we had to earn it
you're just like oh what who is with
this weed
they also it never comes up that i'm
black never talk about it they don't
acknowledge it don't
yo if something happens like where it's
like some black [ __ ] yeah
it's not it's obviously racist yes uh
not ignore like it didn't happen like
george foreign
like we're not talking about that what
do you want to hear your opinion on it
no don't hear my bro if we if they or
they'll be like you know
uh like ask me some a stand-up question
right like like oh so like derek you do
you have you ever met like uh
jimmy afghanistan i'll be like oh
actually yeah like i thought
okay damn it goes nowhere
are you gonna get a job ask me that too
i'm like i didn't have to come here bro
but what's sam say
a heartbroken she's more heartbroken on
just the is she close with the stepmom
closer to the stepmom and
the non-belief like the like hey i'm i
like this is what we've been doing like
way before [ __ ] yeah cover just put a
halt in put a whole you know so
we're figuring it out like we're not
like you want me to stop now also
nine years you want me to stop this yeah
nine and then what do they want you to
do
just and also just like what do you want
me just like get a job just like oh well
you gotta you gotta no i hear you
yeah that's what i'm saying and i'm like
so you want me to work at discount bob's
tire shop in baltimore
but when i didn't even have to come here
but sam's a comic too i know
the and works at the comments and their
head sam's not a comment that doesn't no
bro she was just a girl who had a job
and she's dating me that's what they
were like
what is this are you really doing this
or is derek yo they told her
tell us if they're forcing you to do
this no yeah legit questions
no idea it was just oh you gotta oh you
got a job at that comedy place that
sells
okay did they watch the documentary at
least at all it's not
true it's not really if they're not into
it it's just it's just not a thing it's
just like oh well you're not
you're not also telling them for me to
make it it wouldn't even be like
if i hit like i'd have to be furious
no not even that i'd have to be like oh
he's hosting family feud
yeah look at him he did it they're just
old they're just older they don't
they don't get it and also just not
trying to and that's why i'm like well
i'm not gonna sit here and try to like
tell you what i'm doing old and racist
that's a tough
combination oh yeah you're changing
their mind and then then you know
then you know that you got some anger
because she's dealing with the kid with
down syndrome all the time
bro and that she's never worked and so
like i think that i think that's who
it's just because the dad goes and works
all day does construction comes home
sees me and sam you can tell he's just
like hey yeah what up y'all
[ __ ] yeah y'all over here you in her
space where's her i'm in her space yeah
i'm in her [ __ ] you're just there and
i'm just there yeah my black ass
face
you know you know like sorry what's her
name
sorry amy ate all your pot roasts i got
real high and ate all your pot roasts
you're like these people are ridiculous
cause i'm [ __ ]
those king crab legs that you [ __ ]
bought last week
me and my girl ate all of it i was like
get the
[ __ ] out yeah so you wanted me socks
well yeah man i mean i'll help out with
the kid with downs every now and then
but
i eat all the crab legs i get high i'm
smoking
actually getting on me like [ __ ] this
is so weird it's just a metal meth pipe
you know yeah you might have to get out
of there i got to do it
is there anything to do in maine now is
that open a little bit mains not open no
name bro
i don't know there's no one there yeah
there's nobody there it was me and 32
old white people
hell yeah in the whole state chilling
are you vibing bro what up marianne you
know what i mean uh
but yeah bro that [ __ ] was crazy dawg
that's that energy that energy's so
[ __ ]
when you get before you get back to you
you can when somebody's like get the
[ __ ] out of my house
yo and that hurts more that's just
somebody like yeah you're another day
huh yeah
ooh still here huh still yeah just okay
pot roast up there again yeah yeah don't
try it yeah try it
they know i'd be hot they'd be offered
seconds you know before i finish my
first plate
you're gonna go get another one huh do
you pretty good pretty good huh you're
gonna take something to go huh gonna
take something to go take some
downstairs interesting crazy bro
tough situation but it's one of those
just like man i can't have you have you
been getting up at all
in phoenix yeah that's the only place to
get up but me and chapelle talked about
it earlier he's like he's like bro i've
been to the same
five states yeah i was going to say yeah
we've been you know what else you're
going to do i have
seven offers from just all florida
uh marcos island and i'm like where i'm
like oh an island where is that fiji
it's like nobody it's florida
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song